Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Emre Göktas. Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie. Bevor wir anfangen,
lassen Sie mir Ihre persönliche Daten notieren. Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, geben Sie bitte
mir Bescheid oder fragen Sie nach. Können Sie mich jetzt hören? Ja, ich höre Sie und sehe Sie auch.
Wie heißen Sie? Ich heiße Helmut Schöhn. Könnten Sie bitte Ihr Vornamebuch stabilen?
Im Vorname Heinrich Emil Ludwig Marta Ursula Theodor Helmut. Okay. Von Nachname schön Siegfried César
Heinrich Ö und Norbert. Schön. Okay. Herr Schöhn, wie alt sind Sie? Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Und verraten Sie mir bitte Ihr Geburtsdatum? 56 Jahre alt. Wie alt wäre ich dann? 65. Also, was ist das
dann? Sag mal mal, 15. Mai 1965. Okay. Wie groß sind Sie? Ich bin 1,75 m und wiege 80 kg. Okay.
Sind Sie verheiratet? Ja, ich bin verheiratet. Haben Sie Kinder? Ja, ich habe zwei Kinder.
Ein Sohn und eine Tochter. Was sind Sie vom Beruf? Ich bin Elektroingenieur. So, Herr Schöhn, was kann
ich für Sie tun? Also, ich merke, dass ich so seit ungefähr so zwei, drei Monaten merke ich an mir,
dass ich ziemlich schwach bin, müde bin öfters und bin nicht mehr so leistungsfähig. Schlafe
abends einfach so ein im Sitzen und ich kenne das nicht. Ich weiß nicht, was mit mir los ist.
Okay. Außer Abgeschlagenheit haben Sie noch irgendwelche Beschwerden in diesem Zeitraum? Wie
meinen Sie das? Ich meine, haben Sie Schmerzen oder sonst andere Beschwerden? Schmerzen habe ich keine
Nähe. Haben Sie Fieber vielleicht? Fieber habe ich nicht gehabt. Nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste. Okay.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Gewicht verloren? Nein, Gewichtverlust habe ich auch nicht.
Ich habe schon immer 80 kg oder hat sich nichts dran geändert? 80 kg. Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder meinem Wasserlassen? Nein, nicht, dass ich wüsste. Ich
habe ganz normal regelmäßig immer Stuhlgang und beim Wasserlassen habe ich keine Probleme.
Haben Sie Atemnot oder Brustschmerzen? Nein, Brustschmerzen habe ich nicht, aber wenn ich
bisschen laufe, merke ich mir fehlt die Luft an. Okay, beim Laufen, ja, in Ruhe aber haben Sie
keine Probleme. Leiden Sie unter Herzrasen oder Herzklopfen? Das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie Husten? Nein, Husten habe ich auch nicht. Machen Sie, treiben Sie Sport? Also ich bin
regelmäßig gelaufen, gejockt, manchmal auch so fünf Kilometer lauf, aber das kann ich jetzt
nicht mehr seit zwei, drei Monaten. Das schaffe ich nicht. Warum? Beim Sport haben
Sie beim Sport welche Probleme? Also ich bin schlapp, ich kann nicht mehr so viel laufen seit
zwei, drei Monaten. Sie haben keine Lust? Nein, ich bin schwach, ich habe keine Kraft mehr,
ich kann einfach nicht. Und wenn ich ein bisschen gelaufen bin, komme ich ganz schnell aus der
Puste, weil ich nicht kenne. Ich kriege Luftnot. Okay. Vorher haben Sie diese Beschwerden schon mal
gehabt oder ist das erste Mal aufgetreten? Das ist das erste Mal jetzt aufgetreten, ich kenne
so etwas nicht. Haben Sie bemerkt, am Beine, Schweilungen oder am Beine oder am Ärmel Schweilungen zu
haben? Nein, fragen Sie mal direkt, sagen Sie, sind die Beine in letzter Zeit dicker geworden?
Ja, nee, die sind nicht dicker geworden. Okay, okay. Jetzt möchte ich, ernähren Sie sich gut, wie ist
Ihr Appetit? Also mein Appetit ist schon immer gut gewesen. Ich esse ein bisschen weniger Fleisch,
aber vegetarisch bin ich nicht. Okay, jetzt möchte ich über Ihre vorgeschwere Einpaar Fragen
stellen. Leiden Sie an chronische Alkrankungen oder haben Sie vor Alkrankungen? Nein, ich habe keine
Vorerkrankungen, ich bin eigentlich bisher mal kerngesund gewesen. Okay, Sie haben auch keine
chronische Alkrankungen? Nicht bekannt. Okay, sind Sie schon mal operiert worden? Nee, keine Operation
gab es. Okay, gibt es in Ihrer Familie schwere oder chronische Alkrankungen? Ja, mein Vater hat
Diabetes und meine Mutter hat mal einen Schlaganfall gehabt, aber sonst wüsste ich nicht. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch eine Schwester, der geht aber gut. Okay, sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Mene Kinder? Ja. Ja, die sind gesund, den geht es gut. Schlafen Sie gut, haben Sie Probleme durchzuschlafen
oder eins schlafen? Nee, ich kann eigentlich relativ gut schlafen. Ich habe immer geregeltes Leben
gehabt, ich habe Sport gemacht, bin Teil eines Fett gegangen, habe auch durchgeschlafen, keine Probleme
damit. Okay, gibt es etwas, was Sie sie nicht belastet? Wie meinen Sie das? Haben Sie
Chitres oder in der Familie haben Probleme? Nein, eigentlich nicht mehr als sonst auch.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein? Nein, ich nehme keine Medikamente ein.
Brauchen Sie? Nein, ich hau sie nicht. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Man zeltend, gelegentlich mal bei irgendwelchen Geburtstagsfeiern oder so, aber sonst nicht.
Haben Sie Allergie? Nein, den bin ich bekannt. Okay, möchten Sie, sind Ihnen schwindelig?
Ja, so in den letzten Wochen, das kenne ich vorher auch nicht, wenn ich so Treppen steige
oder so, dann habe ich so das Gefühl, dass mir schwindelig ist, aber sonst habe ich kein Problem mit
Schwindelig. Seit einer Woche, ja? Seit einer oder zwei Wochen, ja. Wie kommt die Attacke oder
wenn nur bei Belastung kommt diese Schwindelig? Ja, nur unter Belastung, richtig. Okay, haben Sie
schon mal Ihre Blutdruck gemessen? Den Blutdruck, ja, den habe ich gemessen tatsächlich, ja. Meine
Frau sagt, ich soll mal den Blutdruck kontrollieren, habe ich gemacht, aber der liegt die ganze Zeit,
du war 130 zu 80, also der ist nicht niedrig oder hoch. Okay, okay, möchten Sie Ihre aktuelle
Anamnese etwas hinzufügen, aktuelle Beschwerden? Nee, nicht, dass ich wüsste. Okay, also das,
was mich so belastet habe, habe ich hin erzählt. Okay, meinerseits habe ich die wichtigste Fragen
gestellt. Haben Sie Fragen, noch Fragen oder? Ne, was schätzen Sie denn, vermuten Sie
etwas? Ist das etwas Gefährliches? Ja, leider kann ich jetzt Ihnen nicht genau sagen,
was Sie haben. Sie haben nur Amtgeschlagenheit, deswegen muss ich noch weitere Untersuchungen
durchführen, dann kann ich Ihnen etwas sagen. Ja, okay, muss ich hier bleiben oder ist das etwas,
womit ich nach Hause komme? Damit wir die erste Untersuchungen durchführen können,
müssen Sie erst mal hier bleiben. Bitte, jetzt nehmen Sie im Barzmachtplatz erst mal,
ich möchte, ich würde gerne Ihnen körperlich untersuchen, danach möchte ich auch ein Röntgen
anorten und EKG veranlassen, danach und möchte ich, ja danach besprechen wir nochmal, okay.
Und Blut wollen Sie mir nicht abnehmen? Doch, ich möchte auch Blut abnehmen. Okay, dann machen
Sie das mal. Okay, der Fazient hat nur einen bisschen Interessant. Okay, ja gut, wir können
weiter machen. Was Sie möchten? Patientenvorstellung oder wollen wir jetzt die Kollegen fragen, ob Sie
noch etwas aufgefallen haben, ob Sie noch etwas fragen möchten, können Sie gerne machen,
sonst in der Zwischenzeit haben Sie Blut abgenommen, Sie haben den Patientenkörperlich
untersucht, auch in EKG geschrieben und wie Sie es gesagt haben, wenn Sie möchten,
weil er Luftnot hat, haben Sie ihn auch geröntgt. Gut. Nehmen Sie Drogen oder haben Sie probiert?
Ne, noch nie. Haben Sie Hüsten? Ne, ich habe keinen Hüsten. Schnarchen Sie? Und ich schnarche,
das müsste man meine Frau fragen, ich weiß es nicht. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft? Ich bin
vollständig geimpft, jetzt auch gegen Corona, drei Mal. Haben Sie Füber? Füber habe ich nicht
gehabt, nein, das hatte der Kollege auch schon gefragt. Haben Sie früher endische Beschwerden?
Nein, vorher hatte ich sowas auch nicht, das hatte ich auch beantwortet, ich kenne sowas nicht.
Sind Sie schon deswegen für diese Beschwerde bei einem anderen Arzt gewesen?
Nein, noch nie, weil in den letzten zwei, drei Wochen wird es schlimmer, deswegen bin ich jetzt
da, vorher bin ich nicht hingegangen. Waren Sie in Deilester seit im Ausland?
Nein, im Ausland war es nicht, schon gar nicht wegen der Pandemie.
Haben Sie Sittan, Trimo?
Sittan oder Trimo, was ist Trimo?
Sittan.
Sittan, das ist Trimo oder was?
Wie bitte?
Sittan ist Trimo, oder?
Ganz genau, ja, die beiden.
Ne, Sittan habe ich nicht.
Also noch eine Frage, diese Frage ist schon unser Kollege gestellt.
Bei Stuhlgang haben Sie bemerkt, die Farbe verändert sich, zum Beispiel etwas so schwarz, dunkel, oder?
Ne, einen dunklen Stuhl habe ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Haben Sie Schwerl bei Ihren Beinen?
Ne, die Beine sind nicht dick, nein.
Haben Sie in Deilester seit das Interesse oder Freude an wichtigsten Aktivitäten verloren?
Noch mal, ich habe sie nicht verstanden.
Wie gesagt, ja, klar, das sogar zunehmen, in den letzten drei Monaten hat es deutlich nachgelassen.
Hatte ich dem Kollegen auch erzählt, ich bin eigentlich ein leidenschaftlicher Läufer, aber ich habe keine Lust mehr, ich kann nicht mehr.
Ich habe nicht mehr die Kraft und ich kann auch nicht mehr laufen.
Aussehenden fühlen Sie sich in Deilester, zum Beispiel, häufig, die der gelassen, traurig, bedrückt oder hoffentlich los?
Ne, das nicht, das nicht. Also mit meinem Gemüt hat es keine Probleme.
Danke Ihnen.
Nehmen Sie Unterstützungsmedikamente von Drogeri-Markt, zum Beispiel Zink oder D-Vitamine?
Nehmen Sie Unterstützungsmittel?
Nein, ich ernähre mich eigentlich gesund. Ich bin ein überzeugter gesund lebender Mensch.
Ich esse auch dem entsprechend, deswegen esse ich auch nicht viel Fleisch, aber schon hin und wieder, Geflügel, Fisch, auch marotes Fleisch, aber nicht so viel.
Ich bin mehr so ein gesund lebender Mensch.
Danke.
Was ist süßet?
Selbstmord, zum Beispiel.
Ne, warum denn?
Und Gottes Willen.
Wenn in Depressionen, zum Beispiel, dann.
Depressionen habe ich nicht.
Ne, willst du noch fragen?
Hallo, ich habe eine Frage.
Können Sie Flaschen liegen oder so wenig Luft zu bekommen?
Noch mal bitte.
Können Sie Flaschen liegen?
Ob ich Flaschen liegen kann?
Ja, damit habe ich kein Problem. Ich sehe eigentlich so wie bisher auch immer.
Also ich muss nicht aufrecht sitzen oder aufrecht liegen beim Schlafen, das ist nicht der Fall. Nein.
Zählt Atemnot oder Nur bei Belastung?
Nur bei Belastung.
Wie viele Stärke, zum Beispiel, können Sie laufen ohne eine Schlöge zu fühlen?
Wie viele Stockwerke ich hochlaufen kann?
Also früher bin ich fünf, sechs, ohne Probleme in einem Zug durchgelaufen.
Mittlerweile muss ich nach jedem Stockwerk stehen bleiben. Ich muss Pause machen, das geht nicht mehr.
Veränderst du dich die Luftnot mit Bewegung?
Ja, wenn ich mich bewege, wenn ich laufe, kriege ich Luftnot. In Ruhe habe ich keine Luftnot.
Ja, beim Sitzen, beim Aufstehen.
Beim Sitzen habe ich keine Luftnot, nur wenn ich aufstehe und laufe.
Haben Sie bemerkt, ob die Augen verändern?
Wie meint ihr das? Das heißt Augen verändern? Augenfarbe?
Ja, weiße oder gelbe.
Ob die Augen gelb geworden sind? Nein, sie sind ganz normal.
Nein, so eine Farbänderung habe ich nicht bemerkt. Meine Frau hat mir auch davon nichts gesagt.
Haben Sie einbrochen?
Berechen habe ich nicht. Nein.
Also, wann haben Sie letzte Mal ein Blutest gemacht?
Bei meinem Hausarzt, das ist vielleicht zehn Jahre her.
Was haben Sie letzte Corona-Impfung im Pennassen?
Sie meinen jetzt die Booster-Impfung? Ja, genau.
Das war Ende November gewesen, also ungefähr zwei Monate her.
Noch Fragen? Dann können wir mit Patientenvorstellungen anfangen vielleicht?
Ja, können wir machen.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt. Heute möchte ich Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen.
Er heißt Helmut Schoen. Er ist 56 Jahre alt, 80 Kilo, 175 cm groß.
Er klagt über Abgeschlagenheit seit zwei oder drei Monaten.
Er leidet auch unter Diskneu beim Belastung.
Manchmal hat er auch Vertigo, wenn er Treppen steigt.
Und sonst hat er seit einer Woche Vertigo.
Aber im Deutschen wird dieser Begriff nicht so häufig verwendet.
Es ist sicherlich ein medizinischer Begriff Vertigo, aber man sagt Schwindel.
Er hat Schwindel seit einer Woche beim Treppensteigen.
Und sonst hat er keine Beschwerden.
Und Fieber, Schmerzen, Berückschmerzen, Gewichtverlust, Hüsten.
Er ist unaufwählig, hat keine Operation.
Er hat Trombostopinie, Anämie und Lykostopinie.
Und Bilrubin-Werte ist hoch.
Nein, ja.
Und LDH auch hoch.
Das heißt, nach dem serigen Angaben gehe ich von, gehe ich von, von einem Anämie vor.
Aber, was für ein Anämie?
Hemmolitik-Anämie.
Möglicherweise, ja.
Wie können Sie das erkennen? Woran erkennen Sie, ob das eine hemmolitische Anämie ist?
LDH ist hoch, deswegen habe ich gedacht.
Ja, reicht allerdings nicht aus. Da muss noch etwas dabei sein.
ACTH, ALT muss man kontrollieren.
Ja, das auch, aber das gehört nicht mit dazu.
Die Hemmolise hat zwei, drei Parameter, wonach Sie gucken müssen.
Das ist einmal die Cholestase-Parameter, sprich, Bilrubin muss erhöht sein.
LDH muss erhöht sein.
Und was muss niedrig sein oder fast null sein?
Das Haptoglobin.
Dann haben Sie eine Hemmolise, das ist richtig.
Aber wenn Sie sich jetzt das Blutbild nochmal angucken,
dann sehen Sie, dass mittlere, korpuskuläre Hemmoglobin ist sehr, sehr hoch.
Ist nicht bei 32, sondern bei 36 Picogramm.
Und was heißt das für Sie?
Das heißt, Megalo-Blaster, die Erritrozytten sind viel zu groß.
Okay.
Ja.
Und da hat jemand gefragt, was ist mit Ritikulozytten?
Die Ritikulozytten sind nur ein bisschen erhöht.
Ja?
Nicht bei 15, sondern vielleicht bei 25.
20.
Okay, aber.
Gut.
Jetzt müssen wir weiterarbeiten.
Jetzt haben wir gesagt, der hemmolisiert.
Das ist klar.
Jetzt müssen Sie gucken, welche Erkrankungen oder welche Ursachen lösen eine Hemmolise aus.
Wenn Sie die Ursachen ausgeschlossen haben,
müssen Sie auch an eine Autoimmunhemmolise nachdenken.
Ja?
Und das können Sie alles aus dem Blut teilweise herausfinden.
Wie finden Sie eine Autoimmunhemmolise?
Eine Auto, ja, Aihm, Autoimmunhemmolitische, Anämie, sagen wir dazu.
Aiha, ja?
Das können Sie einfach mit dem sogenannten Cumst-Test machen.
Ja, da schicken Sie einfach Blut ins Labor und sagen, Sie möchten einen Cumst-Test haben.
Direkt der Cumst-Test, ja?
Abgekürzt mit DCT.
Und da macht das Labor den direkten Cumst-Test.
Und die haben aber keine Autoantikörper gefunden.
Sprich, eine Autoimmunhemmolitische, Anämie ist es nicht.
Das ist ausgeschlossen.
Was machen Sie als Nächstes, wenn Sie so etwas sehen?
Können Sie einfach, Sie haben ja schon bei der Anamnese etwas ausgeschlossen.
Er trinkt kein Alkohol, ne?
Alkohol kann so etwas machen?
Ja?
Warum?
Weil Alkoholika ein Verbrauch von Vitaminen haben, zum Beispiel Termin oder ähnliches.
Und die entwickeln auch eine Knochenmarkschädigung,
eine alkoholtoxische Knochenmarkschädigung.
Die können auch mal so etwas haben.
Aber Menschen, die kein Alkohol trinken und keine Erkrankungen haben,
was kann bei denen passieren?
Vor allem, wenn jemand zu wenig Fleisch ist, wie dieser Mensch.
Oh ja.
Dann B12.
Sehr gut.
Also das kann eine Vitamin B12-Mangel-Situation machen.
Und was machen Sie?
Also Sie bestimmen erst mal Vitamin B12.
Und was machen Sie gleich mit, wenn Sie Vitamin B12 kontrollieren?
Ermitteln.
Ne, ein anderes Vitamin macht das Säbelproblem, eine Megalo-Plastere.
Ziamin.
Und zwar die Kohlsäure.
Kohli.
Ja?
Kohlsäure.
Der Mangel macht genau das gleiche Problem wie Vitamin B12 auch.
Sprich, Sie bestimmen im Blut einfach Vitamin B12 und Vorsorge.
Jetzt haben Sie es gemacht und das ist beides niedrig.
Dann haben Sie Ihre Diagnose schon.
Ja?
Dieser Mensch hat eine Megalo-Plastere-Anämie.
Jetzt müssen Sie aber gucken, warum hat der Mensch ein Vitamin B12-Mangel?
Dazu müssen Sie wissen, wie denn Vitamin B12 resorbiert wird.
Ja?
Wie wird das resorbiert?
Was wird dafür gebraucht?
Ein Intrinsic-Faktor braucht.
Intrinsic-Faktor.
Ja?
Und wo wird die Intrinsic-Faktor gebildet?
Magen.
Magen, kannst du?
Magen, ja, im Antrum-Bereich vor allem.
Ja.
Und deshalb müssen Sie was noch machen.
Das ist noch nicht unbedingt, aber das wäre sicherlich von Vorteil.
Ja?
Eine Magenspiegelung.
Magenspiegelung.
Eine ÖGD.
Ösofagogastrodo.
Ödenoskopie.
Ja?
Das müssen Sie machen.
Der Mann ist Ingenieur und das ist eine verantwortungsvolle Aufgabe.
Der wird sicherlich Stress haben.
Sie haben den richtigen Richter gehabt.
Wir haben gefragt, ob er mehr Stress gehabt hat oder nicht.
Aber der hat schon sein Leben lang Stress.
Das ist jetzt nicht in letzter Zeit mehr geworden.
Und Stress kann so etwas natürlich begünstigen.
Ja?
Und jetzt lassen Sie den Spiegel und die gucken da rein und sagen,
ja, so ein etwas atrofe Schleimhaus.
Ja?
Und eine Typ C Gastritis.
Mhm.
Und dementsprechend sagen wir dann,
das ist eine Perniziosa.
Ja?
Der Mann bildet einfach zu wenig Intrinsic Faktor.
Und dadurch kann er aus der Ernährung sein notwendiges Vitamin B12
und Volsäure nicht aufnehmen.
Und dadurch hat er, sagt man,
einen nutritiven Mangel von Vitamin B12 und Volsäure entwickelt.
Und im Rahmen dessen können sich die roten Zellen nicht mehr
vernünftig ausbilden.
Werden sozusagen als unreife Zellen in die Blutbahnen gegeben,
sterben aber ab, die hemmulisieren einfach.
Und dadurch entsteht eben diese Konstellation.
Das Knochenmark ist erschöpft.
Das kann nicht mehr viel nachbilden.
Ja?
Die Reserven sind aufgebraubt.
Und deshalb hat er eine LDH von 5000.
Und das Bilirubin ist nicht so hoch.
Ich hätte jetzt erwartet,
wenn jemand eine LDH von 5000 hat,
dass der auch ein Bilirubin von 6 oder 7 haben kann,
vielleicht sogar höher.
Aber das muss nicht immer der Fall sein.
Sie müssen nur daran denken, dass es auch niedrig sein kann.
Und so eine Perniziosa, Vitamin B12 und Volsäure
kann auch eine Trombozytopinie und auch eine Leukozytopinie machen.
Das muss nicht nur mit einer Anämie einhergehen.
Das will ich damit sagen.
Warum?
Weil das Knochenmark völlig krank geworden ist durch Vitaminmangel.
Und dann sind auch die Vorstufen der weißen Reihe
und auch der Trombozyten betroffen.
Nicht immer nur bei Anämien an den roten Denken,
auch an das Gesamtbild Denken, das für die Klamotbetonen.
Jetzt haben wir die Diagnose gestellt.
Also, sie haben das im Blutekampf, sie haben manches ausgeschlossen,
keine alkoholtoxische Knochenmarkschädigung.
Und sie sehen im Differenzialblutbild,
wenn man die weißen Blutkörperchen auftrennt, auch keine Was.
Das müssen Sie nämlich von Anfang an ausschließen bei der LDH.
Keine akute Leukämie.
Akute Leukämie.
Ja, das Differenzialblutbild ist völlig normal.
Der hat keine Blasten, der hat keine Vorstufen
im Sinne von Metamiolyzyten oder Promiolozyten,
sondern das reift schon aus, aber ist ein bisschen niedrig.
Und Sie haben keinen Hinweis für eine akute Leukämie.
Weil das müssen Sie zuerst machen.
Das haben Sie auch gemacht.
Und dann haben Sie gesehen, der Mann hat einen Mangel an Vitamin B12
und Vorsorge.
Und jetzt müssen Sie einfach konsequent die Therapie machen.
Was machen Sie bei DiMes?
Wir haben B12 Tabletten geben.
Injektion geben, erstmal.
Ja, warum keine Tabletten?
Weil die, erstmal die B12-Vitamin,
wie kann man das sagen?
Intrinsik.
Auch Intrinsik-Faktor müssen wir auch geben.
Aber egal, ob Sie ihm jetzt eine Tonne Tabletten geben
mit Vitamin B12, er kann es nicht reservieren.
Deshalb müssen Sie das Ganze umgehen.
Sie geben ihm direkt entweder Im oder IV.
Sie können auch Subkutan geben, aber Sie können auch Im geben.
Das wirft genauso gut.
Sie geben ihm Vitamin B12.
Und was schätzen Sie?
Wie läuft so etwas ab?
Haben Sie so etwas mal gemacht?
Wie die Behandlung so aussieht?
Nein, ich habe keine Erfahrung.
Also, jetzt müssen Sie sich vorstellen,
eine Fabrik, wo Sie Vitamin B12 mangel haben.
Und wenn Sie das dann plötzlich da reingeben,
dann sagt Ihr Knochenmark,
Hurra, jetzt habe ich wieder was.
Ja, jetzt kann ich wieder die Maschinerie anschmeißen.
Was passiert dann?
Ja, jetzt wird das Knochenmark, ich sage mal, rebellisch.
Ja, das Knochenmark versucht jetzt,
alles, was notwendig ist, ganz schnell zu bilden.
Wir hatten ja gesagt, ein Hemoglobin von 3,9.
Hätten Sie diesem Menschen dann Blut gegeben bei dem Habi?
Blut?
Ja, vielleicht können wir geben, weil...
Aber nur hatte er Atemnot beim Belastung,
sonst hatte er keiner beschweren.
Deswegen müssen wir nicht dringend ein Blut geben.
Nee, ich hätte ihm auch nicht gemacht.
Wenn er jetzt jemand gewesen wäre mit gewissem Risiko,
zum Beispiel eine coronare Herzkrankheit
oder eine schwere AVK,
dann hätte ich gesagt, oh, oh, das ist gefährlich.
Der kann natürlich eine Myokitischemie und so weiter entwickeln.
Dem muss man ein bisschen Blut geben.
Da fragen jetzt die Kollegen, ob man irgendwie Eisen substituieren soll.
Hat er denn einen Eisenmangel?
Der hat keinen Eisenmangel.
Er blutet ja nicht.
Er hatte keinen Eisen verloren, also wird er auch keinen Eisen brauchen.
Was er braucht ist Folsäure und Vitamin B12.
Das sind die Substrate, die er jetzt maximal verbraucht.
Was wird er jetzt entwickeln?
Sie können die Blutbildung mit einem Parameter jeden Tag kontrollieren.
Ob die Blutbildung jetzt deutlich besser wird oder nicht.
Sie müssen 2, 3 Parameter regelmäßig kontrollieren.
Sie gucken einmal nach den Rettikolozytten.
Wir hatten gesagt, die Rettikolozytten sind nur bei 25.
Wissen Sie, was passiert, wenn Sie dem jetzt Vitamin B12 und Folsäure geben,
dann geht das über 200 oder 300 Rettikolozytten.
Man spricht dann von der Rettikolozytten-Krise.
Die LDH geht zurück.
Hoffentlich wird irgendwann auch das Haptoglobin wieder größer werden.
Aber das braucht Zeit.
Aber wie gesagt, Sie müssen diese Menschen Folsäure mit Vitamin B12 geben.
Auch wenn Folsäure noch normal waren.
Dadurch, dass er jetzt vermehrt Blut bildet, verbrauchte er auch Folsäure sehr viel.
Dementsprechend gebe ich diesen Menschen meistens immer Folsäure mit dazu.
Manche sagen, das ist nicht notwendig.
Aber ich habe die Beobachtung gemacht, dass manche Leute innerhalb kürzester Zeit
von einem normalen Folsäure-Wert kommen, innerhalb weniger Tage einen Mangel entwickeln.
Deshalb gebe ich dann von vornherein Folsäure z.B. mit Folsäuren 5 mg vorübergehend
für einige Wochen und dann sagen Sie, ich brauche sie nicht mehr,
wenn die Blutbildung wieder normalisiert ist.
Wie gesagt, Sie können kontrollieren, was dann passiert.
Sie werden dann merken, wenn Sie Vitamin B12, wie oft geben Sie Vitamin B12?
In der Anfangsphase und wie sollte man das dann fortführen?
Erstmal jeden Tag, eine Woche lang, dann einmal pro Woche, dann einmal pro Monat.
Nach dem Motto viel hilft viel, das ist nicht ganz korrekt in diesem Falle.
Sie müssen nur die Depots vollmachen.
Ich mache dann gewöhnlich immer so eine Ampulle erst mal vier Wochen lang,
einmal die Woche.
Sie müssen nicht jeden Tag Vitamin B12 geben.
Das reicht natürlich aus.
Vier Mal wöchentlich, dann gebe ich dreimal pro Monat, also dreimal monatlich.
Dann sage ich, alle drei Monate einmal als Erhaltung.
Das ist für meine Vorgehensweise.
Jeder hat sicherlich eine andere Vorgehensweise,
aber damit habe ich eigentlich sehr gute Erfahrungen gemacht.
Meistens brauchen diese Menschen ungefähr, sage ich mal, drei Wochen,
bis der HB-Wert relativ gut wieder angestiegen ist.
Wenn Sie die Hemolyse damit stoppen, dann werden Sie merken,
jeden Tag geht das Hemoglobin hoch, die Leukozytten normalisieren sich
und auch die Tombozytten steigen.
Und bis er sein ganz normales Labor wieder erreicht hat,
werden sicherlich so zwei, drei Monate vergehen.
Das müssen Sie wissen.
Aber wichtig ist, dass Sie die Therapie erst mal beginnen.
Dann frage ich eine nächste Frage.
Wenn Sie jetzt gemerkt haben, sein Hemoglobin steigt
und Sie sind jetzt so bei sieben.
Die LDH ist nur noch bei 1.500.
Die Leurubin hat sich normalisiert
und dem Menschen geht wieder sehr, sehr gut.
Was machen Sie mit dem?
Bleibt er noch da? Wie lange?
Oder geht er nach Hause?
Ja, intrinsisch.
Muss man lebenslach lang diese oder...
Man aber auch der Hausarzt machen.
Dafür ist der Hausarzt da.
Er hat jetzt nur die Therapie eingeleitet, begonnen.
Und Sie schreiben einen Brief.
Und den Brief bringt er zum Hausarzt.
Und der Hausarzt muss ihm in seiner Praxis
weiter Vitamin B12 spritzen.
Aber diesen Menschen können sie jetzt entlassen.
Der kann nach Hause.
Er muss nicht da bleiben, bis er ganz normalisiert ist.
Ja.
Und dementsprechend mache ich dann immer so,
wenn Patienten
vom Hemoglobin her deutlich besser geworden sind.
Ich hab Video ausgeschaltet.
Vom Hemoglobin, wie tendenz hoch geht.
Das heißt, der steigt.
Und die LDH geht wieder deutlich zurück.
Dann lasse ich die Leute nach Hause.
Ich rufe den Hausarzt manchmal an.
Sage dem die Dringlichkeit.
Und Vitamin B12 würde er spritzen.
Und Vorsorge schreibe ich ihm bei Entlassung auf.
Und das würde er bitte noch ein paar Monate fortführen.
Und dann kann der Mensch wieder nach Hause.
Dann hat er sein Problem überstanden.
Ja.
Und wegen dem Magen
muss man sicherlich mal im Verlauf,
vielleicht so in drei Monaten oder in sechs Monaten,
nochmal eine Kontrolle machen, um zu schauen,
ob sich diese chronisch adrofre Gastritis,
die C-Gastritis, ob die sich gebessert hat oder nicht.
Ja.
Da muss man nochmal Gastroskopie machen.
Bitte?
Muss man nochmal Gastroskopie machen.
Ja, im Verlauf.
Das soll aber ein Gastroenterologe noch mal entscheiden.
Das ist seine Aufgabe.
Gut.
Soweit verstanden?
Ja.
Eine Frage.
Normalerweise so eine Patientin,
eine neurologische Zentrum auch sein.
Zum Beispiel Tremoren
und die Reflexen, Hyperaktiven
und manchmal psychologische Probleme
wegen dieser Stalkerbezirch-Vitamin-Magen.
Das muss nicht immer sein.
Wir meinen jetzt so wie bei Alkoholikern.
Ich verstehe es.
Aber gewöhnlich haben diese Menschen
eigentlich keine neurologischen Probleme.
Ich habe es noch nie erlebt,
dass Patienten mit einer Perniziosa
auch gleich neurologische Symptome ausweisen.
Das habe ich noch nie beobachtet.
Das ist keine innenmedizin.
Das kann ich nicht sagen.
Bei einer Knochenmars-Toxischen
würde ich auf jeden Fall machen,
wenn jemand eine alkoholische Problematik hat.
Das ist schon richtig.
Aber wenn jemand eine reine
Vitamin-bezirk-Mangel-Problematik hat,
dann mache ich das meistens nicht,
weil die Leute haben ein akutes Problem
im Sinne der Anämie
und dann haben sie eigentlich selten
neurologische Probleme,
die sich mittlerweile manifestieren.
Das habe ich noch nie beobachtet.
Danke schön.
Weiteren Fragen?
Ja, sollte man hier Knochenmars-Toxischen machen,
weil es hier Transitopinie gibt?
Ist nicht notwendig.
Nein, nein.
Wenn Sie jetzt gesagt hätten,
Vitamin B12 ist völlig normal
und Vorsäure ist normal,
dann hätten Sie die Frage gehabt,
kann er vielleicht Vitamin B12 und Vorsäure
nicht verbrauchen oder nicht einsetzen?
Dann hätten Sie sagen müssen,
der hat anscheinend ein Bildungsproblem,
kein Mangel, sondern ein Bildungsproblem.
Und in dem Fall hätten Sie dann eine diagnostische
Knochenmars-Toxin,
das ist nicht notwendig.
Man muss es wahrscheinlich machen.
Aber in diesem Fall,
wenn alles zusammenpasst,
und Sie haben eine nachgewiesene Vitamin B12-Mangel
und Sie haben auch noch die chronisch atrophige
Gastritis, dann brauchen Sie keine
diagnostische Knochenmars-Funktion.
Das ist nicht notwendig.
War das hilfreich?
Ja, das war hilfreich.
Ich habe immer Probleme
mit solchen Patienten.
Wie kann ich
solche Patienten
untersuchen?
Deswegen war das hilfreich.
Und noch eine Frage.
Welche Differenzialdiagnostik
wollen wir denken?
Das haben wir ja schon gemacht.
Leukämie haben wir schon gesagt.
Leukämie, weil es ja eine
Megalo-Plastere-Anämie war,
gibt es da nicht Großartige,
eine alkoholtoxische,
eine gute Differenzialdiagnose
und eine Blutbildungsstörung.
Das kann zum Beispiel auch
eine myolodysplastische Symptome sein.
Das kann auch mit einer
aplastischen Anämie mal einhergehen.
Sprich, dass im Knochenmark
irgendeine Schädigung da ist, weshalb der Körper
nicht mehr ausreichend nachbilden kann.
Da hat der Kollege von vorhin nur in dem Fall recht gehabt,
dass wir zum Ausschluss einer
aplastischen Anämie oder einer anderen Bildungsstörung
eine diagnostische Knochenmarkspunktion machen müssen.
Es gibt manchmal Kollegen,
die denken einfach nicht mit.
Das ist sehr banal,
internistisches Grundwissen.
Was hier in Deutschland bei jedem Arzt,
als Grundwissen vorausgesetzt ist.
Manchmal bekommt man eine Knochenmarkspunktion.
Diese Fragestellungen bekomme ich manchmal
von Gastroentologen.
Da lache ich manchmal und das schimpfe ich auch teilweise.
Der braucht keine Knochenmarkspunktion.
Er braucht schnell Vitamin B12,
Folsäure und Abwarten.
Nicht sofort denken, jetzt habe ich ihm gegeben,
warum wird das nicht von heute auf morgen besser?
Man muss sich vorstellen,
die Zellen leben im Knochenmark oder im Blut
unterschiedlich lange.
Wegen manche Granulozücken, 5-7 Tage leben,
können Erdrozücken, fast 3 Monate leben.
Trombozücken, ganz wenige Tage auch noch.
Dementsprechend muss man auch Geduld haben,
bis das rote Blut, so Pöapö, langsam
wieder in der gesunden Form gebildet wird.
Wenn man sich das Ganze nicht so klar macht,
auch die Vorgehensweise, dann kriegt man Probleme.
Aber Sie müssen ganz strukturiert vorgehen.
Sie schauen, wenn so jemand kommt,
wie Sie das schon so angedeutet haben, jemand mit Luftnot.
Sein Problem war die Erschöpfung, Luftnot,
Müdigkeit, Schlappheit.
Man hat sich auch schon so angedeutet,
dass man sich nicht so gut sieht,
Luftnot, Müdigkeit, Schlappheit.
Wenn so jemand kommt, habe ich sofort immer als
Verdachtsdiagnose, der wird eine Blutarmut haben.
Die fragen, die sind notwendig.
Werden die Beine dicker und können sie flach liegen,
nachts, wenn sie schlafen.
Diese 2 Sachen sind eigentlich ein Hinweis dafür,
ob jemand eine kardiale Düsbknö hat
oder ob das vielleicht eine andere Situation ist.
Wenn er sagt, er kann flach liegen,
in Ruhe hat er keine Luftnot und der sieht blass aus,
der hat keine Üdeme, dann wissen Sie sofort automatisch,
das ist irgendetwas hematologisch.
Er hat eine Anämie.
Dann können Sie ganz schnell im Blut nachschauen.
Sie machen einen Blutbild und dann sehen Sie,
wie hoch ist das Hämoglobin,
wie hoch sind die Erhydrozyten
und dann gucken Sie sich MTV an,
ist das eine Mikrozutere oder eine Makrozutere
und MCHZ, ob das eine Megalo-Plastere ist,
ja oder nein.
Wenn Sie sich dann schon irgendwie
in die Schiene gebracht haben,
welche Richtung das Ganze ist,
wird MTV normales und Sie sehen eine Megalo-Plastere-Situation,
dann gucken Sie sofort nach der LDH.
Die LDH hoch ist das Bilirubin hoch.
Und damit Sie dann eine Hämolyse sofort,
ja oder nein beantworten können,
melden Sie noch ein Haptoglobin nach.
Haptoglobin ist ja das Transportpothein
für das Hämoglobin.
Wenn Zellen kaputt gehen in der Peripherie,
Hämolysieren, dann wird das Hämoglobin
an das Haptoglobin gebunden und wieder in die Leber gebracht.
Ja, und wenn zu viele Zellen kaputt gehen,
dann wird das Haptoglobin mehr verbraucht
und dann können Sie im Blut kein freies Haptoglobin
mehr messen.
Dann sagt das Labor kleiner als 10, also nicht messbar.
Ja, dann haben Sie schon drei Sachen, LDH,
Bilirubin, Haptoglobin, eine Hämolyse findet statt.
Und dann sagen Sie, was ist es denn jetzt?
Ist es jetzt ein direkter, kumpf-positiver
Autoimmunhämolytische Anämie?
Oder ist das eventuell eine Perniziosa?
Ja, und wir haben das dann damit erledigt.
Und dementsprechend haben Sie dann sozusagen geklärt,
ob das jetzt eine Perniziosa ist
oder eine hemolytische Anämie ist
und die Hämolyse, die autoimmunhämolytische Anämie,
haben Sie mit dem direkten Kumpf-Ses jetzt ausgeschlossen
und dann wissen Sie auch, was damit zu tun ist.
Ja?
Ja.
Gut, weitere Fragen?
Okay, gut.
Dann können wir das, denke ich, hierbei belassen
und die Sitzung schließen.